Okay, so good morning, good afternoon. Good evening everybody and thank you for joining.
We have a special guest here today and his name is Manoj Muthavarupu.
Rarapu, excuse me. Manoj is the director of product management. He comes to us from Hyderabad, India today.
And he actually did a session that I went to at Web X 1 on the agent.
And this is something new and different from Cisco.
And so I thought you guys would be interested in hearing more about it.
And so with that, I'm going to turn over the call to Manoj. Thank you, Manoj.
Alright, thank you, Dana. Hello, everyone. Thank you for joining in today.
So we have about 40 minutes or so, right? So I won't do too many slides.
We'll probably just introduce the product and the positioning for about 10 minutes,
and then we'll jump into a demo. And then, yeah, we can come back to slides and do some more material
or we can do Q&A, whatever works for you. Cool. So before we do a deeper dive into AI agents
specifically, I wanted to introduce how we are thinking about the product set from our customer
experience portfolio. We'll not do like a deeper dive into any of these, but at least to give you
the broad pillars and layers, right? So you have all the customer touch points on your left.
These are all the channels that the customers wish to communicate with the business today.
And on the right, you have all the business systems, back office systems,
ticketing and any sort of IT infrastructure that may be there in your business that helps
you communicate better with your customers. So our portfolio kind of plays in between these
two bookends. So the layers are various, so particularly on the bottom ones,
they're basically building blocks and serve as a foundation for the three pillars which are
more of an application level constructs or the kind of workloads that we wish to serve.
So we have proactive journeys, which is being able to communicate to the customer even before
they come in as an inbound contact. We have AI agents, which we'll do a deeper dive into today.
And then, of course, you have the contact center in the form of human agents.
So on the very top, you have the developer ecosystem and extensibility that the portfolio
offers. So today's focus is going to be AI agents, right? So most of this is probably already
obvious to you if you've been in the industry for a while. The demands from the customer side
have definitely been going up over the last few years. This is about wanting to communicate
with businesses on a channel of their choice at a time that is convenient to them.
And in a mode that works for them, right? So typically voice tends to be a very synchronous
channel. You have to be able to serve that kind of contact very quickly by providing
the right agent at the right time from your contact center. And that's a challenge that's
easier solved than said. So what AI agents really help you do is bring in this element of an elastic
supply because you can then instantiate and terminate them on demand without a lot of
lead time training or having to manage some kind of onboarding into your contact center itself.
Right? So they obviously bring you the benefit of containment, which is where a customer calling in
or messaging in to your contact center gets fully served by the AI agent without ever having to
be attached to a human agent. Or even if they do not do that in all the cases,
they definitely help you play the role of a concierge where a lot of repeatable portions
of conversation such as identifying your customer, authenticating them, finding out the
reason for their contact, maybe doing a data dip and serving some preliminary information.
These are the kind of workloads that AI agents can then offload so that your human agents can
then build on top of a summary that these AI agents generate and then continue the conversation
from there on so that they'll actually get lower handling times, better metrics and solve
real problems instead of going through the process. So with that said,
what is WebEx AI agent? So WebEx AI agent is a platform that allows you to build these
omnichannel AI agents, which means you can build an AI agent to serve customers in both
voice and messaging. And in the future version, you could have a multi-model conversation
as well, wherein the customer may be in conversation with your AI agent on voice while
also texting the same business and having a conversational session going on another channel
as well. This could be useful for sending in some images, sending in some transaction IDs,
which tend to be more easy or more convenient on messaging channels versus
having to say them out in a typical voice channel. Now these AI agents can operate
either in an autonomous mode where they leverage large language models and generative AI for
the entire conversational orchestration, figuring out what to say when a customer says something.
So that whole dialogue and back and forth and state management is taken care of by the
large language models in the autonomous case. Or they can actually run in a scripted mode,
which is where you build more traditional machine learning algorithms by bringing in your own
training data. If you're familiar with popular vendors in the market like Google Dialogflow
or Amazon Lex or any of those developer platforms, you can think of this mode as similar to that.
So you define your entities, you define your intents and then basically
code up or write up what the agent must say at different states in the conversation
when they're actively conversing. And then in terms of the jobs to be done for these AI agents,
they can either answer questions from a knowledge source that you attach to them
or actually go a step further and take actions or even do fulfillment on top of those actions
for your customers. By that I mean they'll be able to either connect to a business system that
you might have and post data into it or read data from it, process any kind of automation
logic that may be there already today and basically provide that true end-to-end fulfillment
without just limiting themselves to a conversational wrapper for logging a ticket somewhere
and someone else has to come in and action on top of that ticket. So that's the capability we'll be
demonstrating today. And of course lastly, needless to say, all these AI agents will have tight
integrations with our contact center offering. You'll be able to consume them without
having to rep and replace your contact center flows. So to begin with, we're only exposing them
to be consumed within our contact center offerings, that is our Pebex contact center and the Brem versions,
but in a future iteration, you will be able to just build an AI agent on our platform and
connect it to any contact center out there. With that, I'll switch to a demo of the product
itself. If I can just bring back my browser, hopefully my screen share has come through.
So I'm on the AI agent dashboard right now where you can see the various AI agents that are already
built in my account. So like I said, they can be either of an autonomous kind or a scripted kind.
So today, we'll be focusing more on the autonomous option. So I want to show you how
the create journey looks like to start with. So you can either build one from scratch or build on
top of a bunch of existing templates. So obviously, we're working on expanding this set. Today,
it just has a few handful of templates to serve as a starter kit to reduce the time
it takes for you to build. So I'll just do the start from scratch. And this is where
you take the two important decisions that we briefly touched upon. Do you want the AI agent
to run in an autonomous mode or in a scripted mode? And within whatever mode that you select,
what is the primary function you want the AI agent to play? Now, one question that might
naturally come to you is, do I really have to differentiate between answering questions
and performing actions? Because most enterprise cases would really require both of them to be
available. So this is just a temporary constraint until the GA in January, at which point
this second layer of decision is not necessary. Every AI agent can both work with knowledge
as well as perform actions. But just to help us get there in the process today,
these two are demarcated into separate AI agents. So this is where you make your selection and then
click Next and give a few basic details. You just give it a name and then give it a goal
and select a knowledge base to work with. So in the interest of time, I'll not create one from
scratch, but I'll actually show you something that I've created a couple of hours ago
in preparation for this. So this is the one we'll be looking at today. But before we enter the agent
itself, let's look at how knowledge management happens on the product. So this is your knowledge
basis section. You can create as many knowledge bases as you want. So I have created a simple
restaurant knowledge base for today's demo. It has some basic information. So I've gone to this
web page of Adrop Cafe. So obviously it has a couple of branches here in Hyderabad.
So I've copied some information from the website onto my knowledge base. Like you can see,
it was just literally a copy base where the HTML formatting was also retained and maintained
in the database. So I've added a couple of location information. And then some questions
about can I host parties? What is the benefit of hosting parties in Hard Rock and so on.
So obviously you can use this native knowledge base to scale to whatever level you want. There is
a rich text editor. There are various levels of permissions control here. You can create and
manage your knowledge entirely here if you choose to. But of course, you could also bring in
existing files of knowledge and add them to your knowledge base. So what I've done is,
so the menu at the Hard Rock Cafe in Hyderabad is available as a PDF file. So I've downloaded this
and ingested it into my knowledge base in this cafe. So if you see that, it's not a typical
PDF. It's not well formatted for a demo or easy ingestion. So there's images. There's all
sorts of font. And the information is not really structured to be machine readable.
It's meant to be human readable. So I've already ingested this knowledge base. Now let's see
how I can connect it with an AI agent. So like I said, I just created this a while ago. So you
just give it a simple goal. And in this case, I wasn't very prescriptive. It can be as brief
as saying, answer questions about Hard Rock Cafe in Hyderabad. You can also give it some persona.
You can basically go much more detailed in your instructions if you choose to,
but it's not necessary. That's an optional step to give it a conversational step.
So I also gave a chatty welcome message. So with these two basic things out of the way,
the only other step that you need to do is actually connect it to a knowledge base.
So there are three knowledge bases in my tenant. I've connected it to the Hard Rock Cafe one.
With this much setup already in place, let's go ahead and preview.
So whatever welcome message I've chosen is played back to me. Then I can say, where is the cafe?
And let's go back and make sure that whatever answer we get, we can validate.
Okay. So I got the two addresses, the phone number, the maps link, and so on.
Okay, cool. Are you open until 2 a.m. on Vitis? That's probably the kind of a question
a customer might have. And let's see how I've actually captured these timings, right? So the
timings themselves, they're not really too specific. This is how restaurants and cafes would
list their timings. There's the weekdays, there's weekends, and then some starting time and ending
time. So I could ask the question directly and say, what are your open hours? That wouldn't
have been a very hard one to solve for. But given the sophistication that large language
models bring in, so all such indirect questions are also understood and answered accordingly.
So none of the two cafes are open until 2 a.m. on Vitis is the right answer, as you can see.
Okay. So I want to host a party. Yeah, by now these answers probably won't surprise you.
So whatever information we had created in the party's document is being rehashed.
So let's try out some questions around the menu, right? So I can say something like, hope you serve
salads, okay? So I'm responded back with three different salads with some additional details
about it. Let's cross check, maybe one of them at least. So okay, so I do have three different
salads. The name seemed right, the prices seem right. So it's pretty much accurate. And yeah,
so because this whole thing is backed by a large language model and because I have not given it
explicit instructions, the style of interaction might vary from customer to customer.
To a different customer, it might not give these full details. Maybe it would just say,
yes, we do serve salads. These are the three salads. And then I can ask a variety of follow-up
questions on top of it. And I don't need to ask it in an active voice and use direct references.
So let's say I'm quite busy. I didn't read all of this. But I remember that maybe I have
nut allergy or some of the guests have nut allergy. I do any of them have nuts, okay? So it does say that
the honey citrus salad has some spiced walnuts, okay? That looks accurate. And we can cross check
that with the menu itself. Honey nut salad, spiced walnuts. Hopefully you get the idea.
So like this, you can keep having a real conversation based on whatever knowledge
you fit in. Now, of course, knowledge is only one part of the game. And where enterprises will really
have a value on log is not if these AI agents can just answer questions, but actually connect
to their systems. Maybe I want to take an appointment or maybe I want to do a reservation for a party
that I want to throw. So I'll need many details like the expected number of guests,
what date am I looking to throw the party, what are my instructions on the menu and so on.
So typically, this whole information might actually happen on a contact center with an agent
taking in all these details filling in some system while he's interacting with the customer.
So can we automate or can we achieve that level of sophistication with the AI agents
is the natural next step. So for that, I thought I'll showcase the healthcare
AI agent that I've built, again, very recently, like a couple of days ago.
So this is the other agent category. So it's autonomous and it's taking actions.
And really the structure is more or less the same. So you again, give it a goal.
And then you give it some instructions to follow. And again, you could be as detailed.
So for example, if I show you the other agent that I have here,
which is meant to be for a hospital management system. So I gave a lot more instructions because
I need it to follow a certain style. I need it to obey some rules that I'm setting. So all
those instructions can go here. Or it can even be as lightweight as what I'm doing in this case,
if the entire goal is about just taking appointments. So yeah, so those are the instructions.
And then this is the heart of the agent here. So it has what are called as actions. And inside
an action, it's again, really something simple and easy to manage. So you give it a name.
And then you give it a description of when this action must be invoked.
So in this particular case, I'm trying to fetch the patient details based on a unique identifier.
So every patient registered in Epic has a four digit number preceded by the letter E in a certain
context. So as soon as I get that identified, I want to fetch the details of the patient,
do some validation, or maybe start addressing the patient by his or her name.
So once I define the action, I also define whether I want this action to just be about
slot filling or have slot filling and fulfillment. So slot filling is when typically,
so you just want this AI agent to collect the necessary information, but not really act upon
it. This will be useful where you use these agents inside your contact center flows. Maybe
you don't want to invest in separate automation logic to be wired up directly with the AI agent.
And you just want to handle it within your contact center flow. So that is when you would
choose something like slot filling, where all the gathered details are available as
variables or attributes inside your flow. And then your flow logic can continue
and act upon those variables. But that's less powerful. And the more powerful option is to
actually go ahead and do end to end fulfillment. So that is the mode I'm choosing here.
So I'm again defining the bare minimum details that I would want. If I go to the book appointment
action, you would see other critical information like the appointment date and time also being
captured. So these are essentially the details that are needed to invoke this action. Again,
inside the action, nothing fancy, some description of what this attribute is about
and what data type are we expecting to gather so that the agent can do some validations and
all of that. So for example, in a case like a date, you can define the format also to invoke
this fulfillment. You define whether it is a mandatory attribute or an optional attribute
as well. So once you do all of that, you can then link it up to a workflow on WebExConnect.
Now, those of you who are familiar with Connect may relate to the low code, no code
flow engine that we have in our CX portfolio. So for example, the book appointment flow
will look something like this. Obviously, this is a toy flow. It can become as complex as you want
and you can have 50, 100 nodes inside this. And all of that is just encapsulated in a
in a simple webhook that you can wire up with your AI agent. So this is the webhook that I'm using.
These are the details that I'm capturing and using those details and then invoking some operation on
the EPIC system, which is a healthcare patient management system. So I put in all the necessary
details. I pass the variables that I've captured. And then based on whatever is the outcome of
this operation, I notify the AI agent back. So that's what's happening here in the flow.
So you just link it up to your AI agent and your action is good to me.
So now let's see this in action. Okay, I'll help you.
Okay, so I have one patient ID that I know for sure exists in my EPIC integration.
Okay, so what the AI agent did in the background is picked this up
and executed the fetch patient details by using my patient identifier.
So now it knows what my name is and it is able to retain this information for subsequent actions.
Okay, so then I can say something like show my appointment. So as you can see in the
get appointments action, patient ID is a mandatory attribute, but I did not have to
give that again because I've already given that and that information and context is retained by the
AI agent. Okay, looks like I have a lot of appointments coming in. Now I can choose
to reschedule some of these, cancel one of them, do whatever, right? So let's look at the July
10th one that's too far out into the future, right? So I can say something like cancel the last one.
I don't need to specifically reference that. Now why is it asking me a cancellation reason?
Because I have defined cancellation reason as a mandatory attribute in my
action here. I will be traveling. Okay, cool, spin cancel. So we can verify that it
is actually canceled. Okay, we had 11 appointments earlier and now we have 10 appointments and that
one's canceled. So hopefully you get the idea of how actions really help in driving end-to-end
fulfillment. So that's kind of the autonomous mode which I wanted to showcase today.
So I'll stop sharing and go back to the presentation. We'll do a few more slides and then
we can do question and answer. Sorry, if I, if you run out of time, I'll make sure,
you know, I answer your questions while you're done. Cool. Now, okay, all of that is great.
So autonomous users, large language models, which means many organizations may have some
data concerns. Maybe their security posture is not ready to leverage large language models.
So does that mean we don't have a solution for those use cases? No, this is where the
scripted agents come in, come into the picture. I didn't want to give like a full-blown demo of
scripted agents, but just play a couple of videos of the experience of how that looks like. So
here I'm building a credit card related agent. So you just give a couple of variations of
how someone might express this losing of credit card and you can then use generative error at design
time. So what's happening here is those two examples are taken and then relevant training
data is, is then generated by the system. So if your use case, like maybe, maybe you don't
have existing training data, but you do have a use case to solve with automation. This,
these kind of features can then help you bootstrap and quickly build a bot.
So that's one feature which should tell you that it's not like there's no AI in scripted agents.
It's just that for those use cases where customers want full control, you could still use AI to
build the bot itself or build the agent itself. But at runtime, you will still get a classical
machine learning model, which you may be more comfortable with. And then the other
advantage of going with the scripted model is you can then leverage our channel-aware response
designer, which means the same scripted agent. You can take advantage of the underlying
channel's nuances. So in this example, in WhatsApp, I can respond a bit more smartly by sending
these buttons. Whereas on voice and let's say on a channel like SMS, you won't have that
level of richness incorporated. So you just build your intents and build your agent ones,
and then you can choose to respond differently on different channels. So this is also another
benefit that you get because you're pre-defining all the responses for various intents as a part
of your agent building exercise. Did want to touch upon the high-level architecture and
how we are making sure that the risks of AI are also managed properly. So this is roughly like a
system architecture. So you have AI agents that work in conjunction with the contact center.
So I did not demonstrate it today due to time constraints. But of course, any AI agent interaction
can then be seamlessly escalated to a human agent. The human agent will be presented with a
clean, crisp summary of the conversation till that point so that you don't have to go through
the full transcript. And then of course, the integrations and workflows is something
you have seen in the demo. So you have all these entities. And then the connectivity with
the large language models themselves is through input and output guardrails.
So what that means is every request that we are making to the large language model
goes through a multi-layered guardrail set that has been developed in house in Cisco.
And these could be doing things like they can detect jailbreaking attempts. They can detect
any harmful content or any kind of injection type of attacks that may happen on your data
and so on. So if those things happen, there's a way to detect it and seamlessly recover from it
by not even allowing access to the data. And similarly, on the output, no matter how magical
they might have looked, so the large language models today will still have some propensity to
hallucinate. Although a lot of these guardrails reduce the probability of that, it's still a
non-zero probability. So when such hallucinations happen, do we have a way of detecting it and
then creating a feedback loop in maybe tweaking our knowledge a little bit to support it or
alerting the right people to see whether we have the right
documents ingested or maybe there is overlapping answers which are giving you conflicting information.
So the system can suggest signals like that and then you can go and fix it.
And then these are not videos. I just also wanted to give you a glimpse into the
UX refresh that we are doing. So as I mentioned earlier, this is still a pre-GA product.
We are slated to go GA in January at which point the entire offering will be orderable
via your standard channels. But yeah, so we are also going through UX refresh
and these are some screenshots from how it will look like when it goes GA.
Right? So obviously, a lot more richer and cleaner to give you a standard WebEx product
experience. Right? Lots of analytics, etc., also bundled. Cool. With that, I think
we're at the end of my session. I'll stop there and see if there are any questions.
Team, what questions do we have? So I have a question. Sorry. When you had
those appointments listed, how did you grab those appointments? Did you have like,
I'm sorry if I missed it. When you asked when the list of all the appointments showed up after the
customer asked for the appointments. Sure. So I have a get appointments
action listed here and it is calling a specific workflow. And the workflow looks something like
this. So I had shown the book appointment workflow, but let's go to the get appointments one.
There is this one. So I'm grabbing the patient ID that I already know
and querying an Epic integration that is already there in the system.
So I'm making a get future appointments call and passing the relevant information here.
The output of this operation is then passed back to an API call that will intimate my AI agent
on the relevant appointments. So that's how it works. So that HTTP
node goes back to where? Like if you click on it, do you want to open it?
Yeah, this one goes to the AI agent. So this is a, so if you see in the web hook,
I'm also passing a callback URL and that is what I'm using to communicate back with my agent.
So today this process is a little more manual. So one feature that you can expect by our GA
timelines is not having to do all of this. If you're using an AI agent in your flow,
the flow will know where to post the outcome of the flow to. So you don't even need to do this
step. You just define the variables you want to send back to the agent and that's it.
And then if you had for the same list, I know you said delete the last one. Could you have said
delete the fifth one? And it would have comprehended that.
Yeah, so let's try that. So delete the fifth one. So let's verify that this is the right one,
right? So fifth one is November 18, 3.30pm, November 18, 3.30pm. Okay. Yeah, the November 18th one is gone.
So the sophistication now with, you know, large language model powered conversations,
like anything that you normally say to a human, the way you would expect them to understand,
you can expect that kind of an experience with AI agents as well.
So you have another flow, I'm going to assume, that's doing this job for you where you are going,
like update, update appointments. Yeah, I think you're sending that.
Okay, so you have a flow for basically every action that you need to take.
Correct. So I have an EPIC integration to specifically cancel appointment.
Now, this is how the EPIC integration was chosen to be done. You could have,
like if it was another system, maybe you don't have such granular actions, maybe you just have
an update appointment and then maybe you can pass those details. So it depends on the underlying
integration, but yes, in this case, cancellation is a separate flow. So how do you determine
the fifth one out of that list? Yeah, that is the part where AI comes in, right? So when we make
the large language model call, we pass relevant information from the prior conversation also as
a part of it. So it'll know exactly how to interpret what I'm saying when I say fifth one,
because the previous information is also passed to the agent for reference.
Okay, so I don't have to build anything to determine all of that back and the AI will do it.
I have a question, since we're on this page, because this fulfillment is a select flow,
what other choice other than the WebEx connect flow builder?
Yeah, great question. So as of now, this is the only one. There are no other tools. So originally,
we wanted to integrate with some third party flow builders as well. So that will be on the road map,
but the more important ones will come here. So let's say when you select a flow,
the default one, because we natively integrate with like our own systems,
WebEx connect may be the only one, but let's say you just want to execute some code.
If you're exposed to the scripted agents from our previous iteration called bot builder,
there is the option of writing code within the product itself, and you can execute that.
So multiple options can be expected here, but flow is the easiest and the most convenient one.
Yeah, the code option will be ideal because when I see this builder or studio,
every action with the flow is through the webhook and then HTTPS call. Is there any limit
of concern in terms of flow control? Because if we are dealing a very busy contact center,
many concurrent user, there's any concern where we should consider when we build the system
past the scalability? Yeah, so I mean, connect today handles
reasonably good transactions per second. I'm sorry, transactions per second throughput.
I think it's in the default itself that you get even in the lowest year is probably in
thousands per second. So yeah, I mean, there's many customers who are running campaigns that send out,
we're talking about what, hundreds and thousands of messages in an hour.
So it shouldn't be a problem and even if it is, we'll definitely scale up to
meet the contact center volume and demands. Okay, yeah, since it's a detailed channel,
the slide delay won't be so obvious. I agree. I'm not too worried about that.
I agree. So before voice, that is where we are doing all of the latency optimization.
So on voice, there are even things like while I'm executing a flow,
as soon as I initiate the flow execution, I can also start playing a holding message
saying, please wait while I look that up for you or do that up for you. That kind of keeps
the conversation going for a couple of seconds, reducing the perception of latency.
So all those features are being prepared. That's kind of like comforting the caller or customer
while waiting while we're requiring behind the scene. Exactly. Cool. Thank you.
So I have a question for you Manosh. So you talked about the large language model.
Can you talk about that a little bit more and how that's a competitive differentiator versus Cisco?
Sure. So as you saw here when I was building the agent, there's something called as engine here.
So an engine is a combination of the speech to text module we are using and then the large language
model we are using, the text to speech. Obviously the speech modules are relevant for voice,
not so much for messaging. And also the prompts that we use, the glue code that binds all of this
together. So this entire package is an engine. So today we are using the best available model
out there, best in the sense that it's at the sweet spot of providing us good accuracy,
but also making this commercially viable, so which is the GPT-4O model from Microsoft's
OpenAI service. Now you can expect more engines to be available here in the future at different
price points. So I'd say the underlying large language model itself is not a differentiator for us,
but the way we are wrapping that up in our own prompt engineering, our own guardrails,
our own speech layer and packaging them up to provide different benefits for different contact
center or communications use cases, I think that's where we really bring in the value.
Perfect, thank you. Team, we're getting close to time. Oh, I see Nick Papas has a question.
Are you going to have vertical specific engines in the future, Manoj, such as for healthcare?
Yeah, great one, Nick. So in fact, we were speaking to a partner yesterday,
Spensai, and this came up there as well. So will we ever build a healthcare LLM by ourselves to expose
it for AI agents? Probably not. Will we integrate with those vertical LLMs once they become
popular enough and become a market standard where a lot of our customer footprint exists there?
Absolutely. There is also a third route where one of the roadmap items for
kind of like mid next year is to do a bring your own LLM. And this is where large enterprises
that may have already had a head start in investing in their own AI journeys by either fine
tuning some LLM with their own data or maybe partnering with one of these LLM providers and
getting some kind of fresh custom flavor of those LLMs. If they want to bring in their LLM and
connect to our AI agent, that is something we definitely want to support. So yeah, healthcare
specific LLMs is definitely on the radar, but we probably won't build them in-house. We'll look
to integrate with whatever is the best of the breed. Oh, thank you so much. Yeah, so we're
wrapping up and with regard to roadmap and what's coming, we're working right now through our customer
experience business unit to see if we can get a unified roadmap for you all, our top partners
here that are on this call, so that everybody can see everything in on a quarterly basis and not
have the different roadmaps get out there at different times. So we're working on simplifying
that experience as well. So we are at time. I want to thank each and every one of you for
attending today and giving applause to you, Manoj. Thank you for leading us in the session today,
and I hope everybody has a great rest of the week. Thank you. Bye now. Thanks, Son. Thanks for your
time. Thank you. Bye. Thanks, guys.